all right we are now live so this is the
philosophy pop up for july 2019 and
today i'm going to be discussing a topic
that i was presenting on earlier this
summer that a quite long presentation a
lot of research has been going into it
for quite some time on my part and that
is through mos
so for those of you who aren't familiar
yet with this idea through MOS is it
need it's a greek word and it names
originally this part of ourselves
located in our chest that is concerned
with anger with with competition with
you so you could say getting riled up
social status and it's referenced you
know for example in the Iliad where
Achilles speaks to his thumos about what
he's gonna do and faced with this war
leader Agamemnon who's disrespecting him
and so it winds up playing a role in
early Greek tragedy and epic poetry and
in other venues as well but it's really
with Plato that through most takes on
the greatest importance so with Plato as
I think many of you are familiar with
there's there's three parts to what he
calls the soul the buhei and one part is
particularly attached to the body and
that is the appetites or epithelia
well we know that we have these of
course because we have desires for you
know eating and drinking and having sex
and watching spectacles and all sorts of
other things as well and then we know
that we have this rational part of the
soul that carries out you know good
means ends reasoning that that tells the
appetites hey don't do what it is that
you want to do in this circumstance
maybe do it over there instead because
it you know thinks about what's what's
good for us as human beings and then for
Plato there's a middle part this part
that he calls thumos or the thumb on a
dais the
part of the soul and this corresponds in
his ideal city sketched out in the
Republic to the the warrior class to the
people who are you know protecting the
city nowadays we'd probably like place
firefighters maybe EMTs and all sorts of
other you know police people who are
naturally driven to engaging in conflict
and combat who could be brave or you
know could also be cowardly depending on
how they're trained they could also go
too far sometimes quite easily with with
things as well so yeah that's that's got
it plays a vital role in in Plato's
concept of not just how things work in
the soul but how we ought to understand
ourselves as human beings do MOS is
supposed to do a couple different things
one is it's supposed to have you could
say a protective function or assertive
function in relation to other people in
the social world that we inhabit so when
we're getting angry if we're getting
angry for good reasons
then we're you know we're this this part
of our soul through most is what is
doing it's the part that actually does
get angry and anger can sometimes be a
good thing directed against say
injustice taking place or we intervene
on the part of those who need protection
we reinforce good social rules things
like that the most also plays a really
important role within the Platonic
psychology in terms of how reason that
read that rational part controls the
appetites Plato thinks that it can't do
it just by itself it needs sumos as an
ally so you know the best part of
ourself needs a second best part of
ourselves to help control the worse
parts of ourselves when that's sort of
the story that Plato is telling in the
Republic and he also tells us a few
other things you know each of these
parts has its own desires and play
you know you can have a person who's
demotic where they're rational part is
not particularly developed he credits
the Spartans for being like that you
know and he says that that's a problem
because then you're striving after honor
and social status and victory and you're
not really thinking about you know why
why you're doing it so the rational part
is part of what allows us to keep the
most in line and engaged with the
activities that it should be doing
earlier on in book 2 and also in book 3
he talks about how it is that good for
Mata kin dividuals are actually
cultivated and he talks about you know
the Greek educational system had two
main components one was what we call
gymnastics right luminosity K in Greek
and that means physical exercise not
just you know like getting on the
balance but doing all the other things
as well physical conditioning and the
idea behind it wasn't just to get get
big and tough or to learn how to throw
javelins it was self discipline and
being able to subordinate the body to
the needs of the mind but then there was
this other thing called musica which
does mean music you would study some
music we'd also study some poetry it's
studying poetry you think about the
themes of the poetry like is Achilles
actually a good guy or a bad guy for
getting ticked off and then you know
going off into his tent to sulk those
are the sort of questions that would get
handled in you know that thing so Plato
says if you want to develop your thumos
right you need physical exercise you
need physical activity
you also need musica you need some sort
of education and he even says that you
need philosophy as well he also suggests
you know the role of example that you
know children who are going to be in
this warrior class would accompany their
their parents out to the battlefield and
watch what they do and see how they
handle themselves by the way in Plato
themost
is not a gender specific thing it's not
that men possess it more and women
possess it less Plato says that's
nonsense just read Republic book
for and you'll see that he thinks that
well look book two and three as well he
thinks that you can have you know men or
women who are particularly driven by
their bodily desires and that's their
main focus you can have men or women who
are particularly driven by
competitiveness status and anger and you
can have men and women who are
particularly driven by the rational part
and which which makes them you know
candidates for being guardians Plato is
a early feminist if you understand
feminism in terms of equality right and
a denial of radical gender difference
the two most thing comes up as well in
the Phaedrus although it's not named as
such people usually want to read the
chariot metaphor as being exactly the
same as what's going on and there in the
Republic it's not actually the same
because the good horse doesn't get angry
you know it gets angry the bad horse bad
horse gets angry when you don't let it
do it what it wants to do and reason of
course is the charioteer and then
there's an important discussion of
themost in the Timaeus and that's
important too because that's a text that
does survive the loss of all of other
plato's stuff in the West in the Timaeus
the body excuse me into its mass the
body is in the repository for these
different parts the rational part is
cited up here in the head and then the
neck is like a narrow isthmus right
separating it up from the the lower
accounts as well let me get rid of a
unwanted comment quickly so yeah so the
the through the most is located here and
it's particularly associated in later
writings with the organ of the heart so
that's a quite an interesting feature as
well and then the appetites of course
the belly and
genitals and everything below is is the
appetites the epithelia and that's going
to be important why because Plato is
correlating psychic functions to
particular organs and that's gonna run
throughout the literature so the next
part of the story is Aristotle and I've
got some questions coming up here not
all of them are focused on thumos I'm
gonna give two most enhancing top
priority but I'm gonna tell you the
story of Aristotle then run through
Stoics and epicurean is real quick them
and tell you some of the other parts of
the story so anyway Aristotle doesn't
have with the same psychology that Plato
does if you want to find out what it is
go to the neck of McCain ethics politics
on the soul and a few other works and
you'll see him talking about instead of
themost being a third part of the soul -
Moses is one out of three main types of
or exes which is desire or effectivity
we also need to include kuroi racists in
there which is the you know the Faculty
of choice and we also need to include
the pave the emotions in there as well
but the three main types that are being
discussed are bull ASIS which is often
translated as wish or rational desire -
most which Aristotle names and such and
then epithelioid
desire for for bodily pleasures and
things like that and sometimes he's a
little fast and loose and how he applies
that sometimes like in the rhetoric uses
epithelia where we'd expect to see
through most but for the most part he's
consistent and for Aristotle anger is
still an important and emotion and
important dynamic it's it's rather
unique you could say in a relation to
two other emotions so there is something
retained of the platonic thing and
Aristotle does still retain thumos as a
distinctive type of effectivity and it
does still have an important role in
helping us be assertive and taking care
of ourselves and taking care of others
but it no longer has the function of
disciplining the the emotions or the the
appetites in any important way like it
you used to and
you so you can see that Aristotle few
MOS is still there still important but
it's lost some of its distinctiveness
let me go on and talk about the
Epicureans and the Stoics the Epicureans
we don't really know that much about
unfortunately because we've lost many
other their texts but what we can say is
that we do have this guy filo davis who
talks about anger in his work on anger
and he makes a distinction between or
gay another word for anger and thumos
and he has to do a little bit of you
know shuffling around because the
earlier Epicureans had used through most
as a good thing the Epicureans thought
that some anger is natural it makes
sense for us to feel it's sort of the
stimulus response to threats and and
attack some things like that and then
the rest of anger is based in in what
they called Kino dog see I you know
invalid vain empty opinions and you
wanted to try to avoid and eliminate
that the Stoics viewed anger is always
bad and when they use the word themost
they don't use it to mean a part of the
soul because the storix don't have a
faculty psychology anyway like Plato or
Aristotle did everything that's being
done by the human being is really being
done by the rational or ruling part in
certain configurations and sumos in the
stoic texts that talk about the
different emotions is just one type of
anger one species of or gay and if you
look at areas didymus is epitome of
stoic ethics you see an actual list of a
whole bunch of different kinds of anger
I kind of wish they'd gone into more
detail about that at that point but so
we have we have the Plato on one end we
have the Stoics on another end and we
got Aristotle kind of in between as far
as the the role that through most is
going to play most of the people by the
way I'll say it most of the people in
the present who talked about thumos
which tend to be people like like Harvey
Mansfield or Francis Fukuyama worried
about you know cults
and the loss of a warrior class and
courage or some of the alt writers and
and you know manosphere people who bring
up the most they usually pull some
things out of play-doh but then ignore
everything else that Plato says about
that and they want to prioritize through
most many of them so it's not subject to
the rational part they would be falling
into the same problem that that Plato
was identifying in ancient times and
they usually ignore everything else
about about few Mo's but it's got a very
important history going on the other
thing that I'll say about it is so after
all of this you know Plato Aristotle
some of the wrists Italians like they'll
for asked us there's a guy here ona miss
who wrote a book on anger that we don't
have anymore
and then the Stoics and Epicureans there
are also middle plate mists and middle
plaintiffs like Plutarch
have entire works on virtue and on anger
and use the Platonic tripartite
psychology with insights coming in from
Aristotle and often from the Stoics even
sometimes from the Epicureans to produce
a different psychology you know again in
a history of philosophy you often see
people like you know well here's Plato
here's Aristotle then we have the
Hellenistic philosophers and they are
not really as good and then they don't
they ignore everybody until we get to
like neoplatonist the middle plainness
are very very interesting and are well
worth studying Plutarch wrote all these
great biographies he also wrote all
these these moral treatises and then
there's al canoas who who wrote a he's
not quite so interesting but he wrote
this interesting handbook of snow is
there of platonism and there's others
along the way as well
we also see people like Galen who who's
an eclectic medical writer but who was
incredibly engaged with the psychology
and philosophy of his time doing similar
stuff using a platonic tripartite
psychology identifying thumos with
something close to like the stoic
conception of Dalma spirit or you know
whatever you want to call it running
throughout the entire body centered on
the heart the heart from the time of
Aristotle is associated with the
workings of anger and thumos and so
you know this is some some really
interesting developments that are that
are going on in the history of ideas in
terms of this this faculty or drive or
whatever it whatever we think it happens
to be of sumos so the last thing I'll
say is that among Christian writers
early Christian writers the ones that we
have that actually have something to say
about psychology all of them in red you
know the Stoics the Aristotelian Plato
other plate nests they knew their field
of philosophy and they're incorporating
it now within a larger context that also
includes you know injunctions like and
you know the Sermon on the Mount about
anger and they have to make sense of
that and they're also responding to
issues that are arising within Christian
practice and communities so there's a
lot of really interesting stuff that
they have to say like if I grasp on
takus and John Cassian are talking about
it there's a lot of other John masking
is looking at it from an Aristotelian
perspective there's all this really
great stuff in there that talks about
the need to understand and make sense
out of this Faculty of sumos and here's
I'm gonna start taking questions now and
addressing those here's some of the
option whether whether plato's right
whether Aristotle's right whether the
Stoics right whether all of them are
wrong whether Galen you know is better
at this that's not quite so important
what's important is when we talk about
self-knowledge a lot right you know the
unexamined life is not worth living well
you know the unexamined life would mean
figuring out who the hell you are and
what all these parts of yourself are or
portions of yourself or aspects are
doing and I think reading ancient
authors can often be quite helpful in
giving us insights about making sense of
this especially when it comes to anger
and agra civet ii competition social
status all these things that drive us
much more certainly people like myself
much more than do the the appetites for
sex you know drinking laying around in
the Sun that sort of thing right and
then it's always there and we
to acknowledge that part of our self if
we want to do anything with the rational
part so let me start taking some
questions I'm going to give I'm gonna
give priority to those that are actually
asking about through mos so all right so
Linden Bailey is there any comparison
between Hegel's notion and plato's form
or true knowledge I mean sure you can
compare them but that's that's not
that's not a project really connected
with with this so yeah I would say the
forms could be like part of what the
notion is taking in but they're so so
distant from each other it doesn't make
much difference and to go back to the
food most thing foo most is not what
cognizance forms through most is what
helps us deal with the the day-to-day
stuff that we're encountering and also
plays a role in orienting us in terms of
our ambitions I would say all right I'm
gonna skip over I might come back to
Mike woods question here Lord
Awesome's kind of fits in here can we
properly describe spirituality through
deductive logic you can't describe
anything through deductive logic the
deductive logic is used to create
inferences right it's not used to simply
depict things so and spirituality is
such a vague term I don't know what you
would include in that TD LMX are you
able to talk about later treatments with
foo moans like Heidegger's take on
through most in the enthymeme the seed
of the pave etc I'm not sure what that
is or what the reference is but I don't
know if I read that I don't remember
coming across it I will say this that
Aristotle's but this might be where
heidegger's taking off from Aristotle
says that thumos cyllage eise's right
but well and also you know in the
rhetoric of course the enthymeme is sort
of a
an incomplete syllogism so you could say
that that
fumus itself is n thematic but I I don't
haven't looked at what Heidegger has to
say about it
mr. despair so this is one that comes up
all the time with my students and it's a
common sort of mistake to make
how much was Freud influenced by Plato's
metaphor of the tripartite soul so when
you when you raise questions like that
you got to ask what are you asking are
you saying you know the subtraction of
threes I mean Fred could have gotten
that from anywhere then all right
there's three parts to this well there's
a Trinity right and there's all sorts of
threes well you got to look at is what
the functions are so people get
attracted to this because they start
getting Plato's account and they're like
oh yeah the desires that's the it
because Freud describes it in exactly
that way that the it is this part of
ourselves that has all these desires
that you know we can't really control
and we can't predict and that's the way
Plato does talk about them in the
Republic right
also we're off to a roll now but what's
the rest of Freud's tripartite you know
theory of personality ego and super-ego
so you got to ask yourself what would
ego correspond to would it correspond to
the most because it's the middle part
they're clearly not the same thing at
all you know maybe ego would correspond
to the rational part and then what
super-ego corresponds to thematic part
now there's there's no parallel at all
these are these are doing very very
different things
you know the super-ego is this is sort
of internalized sort of voices or
injunctions that are coming from parents
and other authority figures and they
make you feel bad when you don't do
things because you're such a dirty you
know gross child and and all of that
sort of stuff right and and then the ego
is the thing that actually makes
decisions it's where our locus for Freud
of of our self hood lies I'm just trying
to get the lighting right here but these
are really not the same thing at all
these these two tripartite views of
personality or
the soul and you know they're they're
proposing very different remedies for
how to make ourselves less screwed up so
that that's important um
20:46 could Aristotle be seen as making
an argument unintentionally other than
another slavery thing unintentionally
against slavery and natural same as such
and such characteristics you look and
see there's no such cases no Aristotle
thought that there were natural slaves
he thinks that most slaves are not
natural slaves I mean this is this is a
pretty straightforward thing if you look
at the text he says a lot of people say
that slavery is automatically against
nature I don't buy that a lot of people
think that anybody who's taken as a
captive is automatically a slave I don't
buy that so you know clearly he's got a
much more nuanced opinion what other
people have done with Aristotle in terms
of Antebellum slavery in the south and
in terms of enslaving Native Americans
in in in South America using Aristotle
actually abusing and misusing Aristotle
that's a whole different ballgame but
Aristotle has a complex view on that
let's see all right I may come back to
some of these other ones that are not so
much about that Lynden do you think
Aristotle Plato had more influence on
Christian notions of sex in the body um
neither
I mean Christians are drawing on a whole
set of tradition some of them are
obviously coming out of Judaism some of
them are being influenced by stoicism
massive influence by stoicism on early
Christianity whether we realize it or
not some of it is Plato but it's
filtered through all sorts of other
things because people aren't you know
sitting there reading Platonic dialogues
they're usually reading the plateless of
their time and engaging with them
Aristotle you know really the the the
the importance of that is is later on
right but if we're talking about early
Christianity
they're not really that influenced so
much by Aristotle I mean John - masking
you might point out but he's like what
eighth century so that's not that really
all right mister despair what kind of
recognition are we talking about I don't
think I mentioned the word recognition
for that that's important right who most
does want recognition and and
recognition of all sorts of things it's
not just a simple thing the recognition
by the way this plays a major role
throughout all of Hegel's phenomenology
on air kenan is what's what spirit in
terms of its development is looking for
as self consciousness recognition means
it's being treated like you matter like
it's being granted social status but
social status is a sign that you
actually are being treated as a human
being and when we get angry either for
ourselves or for others it's very often
because we're not being treated as if
we're fully human we're being treated as
lesser than we're being treated as
merely a tool for somebody else or
merely as a threat or as not really
participating in and you may hate for
you know having same rights as other
people you're translated as a respect in
a way as well and this happens in
interpersonal relations too you know
they give me the dialectic of desire and
sexual relations some people just want
to have sex in order to get laid right
well that's bodily appetites some people
want to have sex to impose their will on
others that's demonic but it's a bad
through Matic sort of thing other people
want to have something like genuine
intimacy and feel desired by the other
person and valued by the other person
and also have it be exciting and that's
you know I think that's a place where
you know epidemia and and thumos and
also perhaps the rational part in in
Plato's notion could be said to be
brought together and then coincide all
right Ted LMX can you read through
starts reading of Hegel's through most
I'm not sure what that is what work
that's in but I don't remember coming
across it
Hey hey goalies can you elaborate on
anger please it seems equivocal to our
modern sense so a couple things to say
anger is not anger is not a term that
doesn't have multiple meanings in any
circumstance right so if you're worried
about equity you're probably gonna be
disappointed in doing any psychology
every emotion is messy every Drive is
messy every one of them is an analogical
at best concept so there's that there's
a lot of people out there so there's a
bit of a side note who want to say oh we
can't understand the ancient Greeks and
what they mean by anger because it's not
the exactly the same thing as we mean by
it and modern English people in modern
English mean a million different things
by it to begin with
get a whole bunch of self-help books on
anger see if they all mean the same
thing they don't you know so you know to
begin with we sound as if we have a
single you nickel sense of it here the
idea that we can't somehow understand
what's going on in the oddest in the in
the Iliad or the Odyssey for that matter
or a Greek tragedy complete [ __ ]
that's been peddled by people for quite
a while or they're like wait we don't
really know what emotions were like back
then yeah we do I mean I mean if you
think that then you know you really
should stop reading any any literature
older than maybe nineteen fifty and
don't read any literature by anybody
else from any other culture to because
then you can't understand them either
anger and other emotions like fear you
know joy they're pretty basic now
getting into the nuances of it okay
there might be some differences does
Achilles react in exactly the same way
that we would know but he doesn't react
in the same way all the ancient Greeks
would Andy provides discussions about
why he's doing the things that he does
Andy engages in dialogue what the people
are like you're doing anger the wrong
way so I you know I don't buy this for a
second people like to point to other
cultures or the like the anger is you
know don't with in a very different way
and this this thing that we've gotten
from this ethnographic study that's if
the ethnography was actually right
that's if you know and then when you
bring in somebody from these cultures
where things are
be different you talk with them you're
like you know find out usually they have
the same notions of anger as we do
they're just handling them differently
so all right mr. despair is that an Iron
Maiden t-shirt yep it sure is I have a
lot of concert t-shirts
David fusilli Eric can through most be
understood in secular terms or is it
intertwined in spiritual understandings
I don't know why you're asking that
plato is secular terms
Aristotle of secular terms Stoics are
secular terms so the presentation
actually talks you know only only at the
very end about you know feel of
Alexandria who thought that the most is
always bad he's a sort of weird playtest
Jewish bringing in things from stoicism
as well and then you know this this long
tradition in Christian thought but
thumos was being discussed by you know
in secular ways from the very beginning
so I'm not I'm not sure why why you
would think it's intertwined I mean
unless you're understating spiritual in
a very broad sense in which case secular
and spiritual are not actually opposites
so let's see what else we get how does
one become practically wise is from
James corn even if you understand the
ethical theory behind Aristotelian
virtue ethics that won't necessarily
make you a practically wise person well
there's understand and then there's
understand right there's understand in
the sense of being able to like recite
stuff and argue about it and you know
draw some inferences and then there's
actually understanding in the sense of
being able to put it into practice and
use it within your life and so you know
if you actually do start understanding
on that higher level integrative
understanding you're already doing and
practical wisdom is something that you
develop iteratively it's through
sometimes through failing and them doing
after-action reports and being like wow
that was really dumb and getting you
know the feedback from other people who
are smarter and being able to accept it
sometimes it's through observing other
people and seeing what works for them
what doesn't work for them
but there's a constant dialectic between
going back to the tax and putting things
into practice and I'm thinking about it
right and this is the way it is for any
virtue ethics whether it's Aristotelian
platonic stoic Christian same thing goes
for an essentialist literature same
thing goes for pretty much any practical
philosophy so an Aristotle talks about
this in nikka mckay and ethics he says
there's a lot of people in some of the
Stoics by the way Epictetus mentions
there's a lot of people who are reading
this stuff and reciting it but they
don't know how to live so this is this
is you know the cure for for that is to
actually read more Aristotle but also
try to apply it in practice and then
eventually the practical wisdom
accomplished you know it starts to
accompany it let's see here
do we have any more famos things to do
to do ah Luke LAN do you see a
connection between thymosin duty in the
concha and Prussian sense nope to begin
with you know I wouldn't I wouldn't try
to associate Prussia as such you know
sort of a mindless devotion to duty with
can't anyway I mean what a lot of
Prussians made of contas into basements
of Conte Conte is a very complex and you
know rationally articulated body of work
right but Khan says that you know the
moral motivation of the action should be
respect for you no respect for duty for
its own sake so if you're doing your
duty because you're pissed off or
because you're being competitive with
other people that's not a good that's
not a good reason for doing duty in a
conscience sense this would be a great
way to you know separate cut off from
you know admirers of Prussia you could
be kind of a Prussian prick and angry
all the time and like enforcing your
duties you wouldn't be a Concha in any
good sense let's see here
little clan could you say more about the
concept of honor the the left cease
honor as only- perhaps the right is only
positive how can the ancient stop well
that's totally wrong okay there are
there are people on the left that see
left
that's the honors is good there's people
on the right who don't don't see honor
is good
it's not a left/right thing you could
talk about traditional conceptions of
Honor but there's more than one you know
concept of Honor out there so here's
what I would say virtue ethics offers us
standards that even in Aristotle's own
times as you can see I'm talking about
this in politics you know book four and
book five for example where both the the
you know the rich and the many
understand justice to a certain extent
and also get justice wrong right we
could say that about many other things
many other dividing lines in our own
culture and politics if you're a virtue
ethicists you're not going to be
particularly happy with left or right
and you're gonna think that most of them
have have things fundamentally wrong but
left and right are not monolithic
constructions right there's many
different ways of being right many
different ways of being left and so
you'd have to look at each one of them
individually so all right o'sullivan
factor it seems like many of the
politeness ultimately decided to follow
the Stoics on anger were there any who
found value in thumos I don't know what
platanus you're referring to because
very few of them followed the Stoics on
that most plaintiffs what made them
plateless is adopting a tripartite
psychology and saying that there was
there was a role for through most or for
anger by the way anger is only one
activity of through most courage is
another right
that's the virtuous Oh ciated with it so
I don't know what Platon is you're
referring to because pretty much every
plate inist that I've come across who's
an actual plate inist and even some who
are just sort of fellow travelers with
the Plato's reject the stoic conception
reject the stoic critique of anger
reject
the you know stoic reduction of faculty
psychology to the ruling part so can't
really answer the app let's see here
proem does the thumos take the prime
role and more passive actions that
aren't rational per se like
acknowledging beauty doesn't really have
anything to do with acknowledging beauty
as far as I know in any of the people
who I've read so you know through most
for these these people who have in a
moral psychologies it has a pretty
clearly defined role it's about anger
courage competitiveness dealing with
threats social status recognition those
sorts of things it's it's not about
other things I mean Aristotle says that
it's part of what makes us fit to rule
it also has to do with friendship to
some degree but it's it's it's not like
a catch-all for everything and it works
within a system of other parts or
faculties all right um let's see here
[Music]
MX 25a is there a relation between the
concept of themost and that of the
hoplite a well-disciplined and trait a
soldier an opposition of the Homeric
warrior there isn't a concept of I felt
like people went around you know
preaching the concept of the hoplite
that's sort of a modern reconstruction
of something that was going on there
yeah I mean why would there be any more
through most in a hoplite than there is
in a Homeric warrior suddenly Homeric
warriors didn't by the way line up in
lines and have Spears and were fairly
well disciplined it's not like they I
mean if you watch movies right they're
all running and you know engaging and
things but it wasn't just a free-for-all
you know and you can say well what about
the Romans you know the you know the
Roman early maniples and and then the
you know the later reorganizations and
stuff like that
anybody who's a warrior through most is
involved and and it can be good or it
can be bad right the question isn't
whether you've got through most the
question is how screwed up is you're
through blows you know like are you
you know after you take the city do you
sack it and like kill everybody out of
revenge revenge is also a function
within those two so all right Patrick
Walters is Hobbes restricting of themost
under the Wyeth on contradicted by the
need for a thermal filled individual to
form Leviathan you're talking about the
sovereign right because the sovereign
doesn't form Leviathan the sovereign is
somehow put in place and the sovereign
doesn't have to be thematic the
sovereign doesn't have to be you know
some sort of angry jerk all the time as
a matter of fact if if Hobbs Hobbs II
and Leviathan is really going to work
well it probably would be you know you
know Mort Mort in some respects more
stoic than platonic you know or it would
in other words it would do the things
that are required by reason without
needing to get angry you know Hobbs says
if the sovereign does get angry well
that's up to the sovereign you don't get
to pass judgment on them right
and it's not just the most that Hobbs is
looking to control right competitiveness
in the sense that Hobbs talks about is
not like competition for honor there
remember there's three main sources of
conflict for hops in Leviathan only the
last one is actually thematic and that's
vanity the first two are actually
alternately rational and you know
appetite it you could say it calls a
competition you've got a house I want
your house there's nothing thematic
about that I just want to take your crap
and if I have to kill you that's okay
the second one diffidence or
anticipation is much more rational oh I
know that I would like to take your
house and I got a nice house too so if I
think about the fact that you're like me
you you dirty bastard you're gonna try
to take my house so I better kill you
first right there's nothing particularly
thematic about that you could you could
you could have people who are just
greedy and strategic thinkers
and they need to be controlled in the
Leviathan all right let's see here
Gabriel Sutherland so platonic idealism
is still a secular philosophy category
mistake you want to call it secular go
ahead I mean it wasn't religious you
know in the same sense that we talk
about religion today I wouldn't worry
about that I would worry first about
understanding Plato and then you can
figure out stuff like that later right
let's see here
Lyndon Bailey what are some valid
criticisms of the through most epic ooh
most idea do you mean like that there's
a distinction between the two of them I
mean you know here's where it comes down
to there it's not as if there aren't a
whole bunch of different moral
psychologies out there and one could say
well from the vantage point of this
moral psychology like that of say
cognitive behavioral therapy and the
underlying psychology behind that the
Platonic conception or the Aristotelian
conception that's wrong yeah but other
than the fact that CBT seems to work but
nobody actually knows quite why it works
correct or other other rational emotive
you know behavior therapy the clones
why do you need to prefer that one and
take that as absolutely being true and
this one has been being the subject of
that you place them in dialogue with
each other at a certain point you gotta
like you got to decide for some sort of
moral psychology and there's there's a
variety of them out there so many of
them have no roles for faculty
psychology anyway all right let's see
what else we get Liu clan putting aside
interpretive issues with ancients what's
your assessment of Mansfield relating
famos and manliness well to begin with
we don't put aside interpretative issues
with ancients because the ancients still
speak to us today and Mansfield is
somebody who's drawing on the ancients
oh you know there are these people who
later they're always like forget well
forget the whole history
you know I'm not interested in all that
sort of stuff what do you mean in the
present why our president is informed by
that history and the people in the
history offer us illuminative accounts I
tend to think that the lot of the people
who are talking through most today
are hankering after an idealized culture
that that never really existed or only
existed in little pockets and they would
love to have that because they're
terrified so there's one they're
terrified of change to begin with
they're terrified of degeneration and
they're also worried that there aren't
gonna be enough people who are thematic
in the present to to successfully defend
us you know
big worry on the part of people like
Mansfeld for example as well what are we
gonna do about rising China and I think
that a lot of these worries you know
people are also worried about like
traditional masculinity and all that if
it's worth a [ __ ] it's gonna it's gonna
survive you know we don't need to put
things on ideological life support what
we need are things that are actually
adaptable enough to get us into the
future that we're going to be inhabiting
so that we can actually talk to the
people who are coming after us in
meaningful ways and they're not all
looking at us like man what those people
were dumb they were really stuck back in
their old ways of thinking and and the
you know the reason why we're still
reading Plato and Aristotle and the
Stoics is because they were like that
they don't just talk about their own
time and its own you know particular
weird cultural configurations you know
the question about Aristotle and slavery
is a great example of this if you
brought a Aristotle here today and you
sat him down he said here's your here's
the other stuff that you're saying do
you want to revise your stuff on slavery
he'd have done it in the heartbeat and
and that's our job is to reinterpret
that that sort of thing so I'd say that
that's sort of my thing yes onus is
being kind of pedantic here as a
sidenote through Moses pronounced the
most with an accent I know it's
pronounced however the hell we want to
pronounce it or speak in English you
know I'm not going
say Socrates you know this that that
sort of thing man I've been reading
Greek for what two decades what do you
care
the stuff people write sometimes it's
important to get that con sense right
let's see who else we've got here ah
Natalie it's the most inherently
spiritual would it still stand if
someone rejects any mysticism sure yeah
I mean it depends on what you mean by
mysticism because mysticism is one of
those super ambiguous terms it means a
whole bunch of different things to a
whole bunch of people is it inherently
spiritual depends on what you think
about the personality or the psyche
right if you if you think that the
psyche is something spiritual sure if
you're an Aristotelian and you think
it's the form of the body and it's what
animates us and keeps us alive maybe not
right all right let's see Orpheus here's
the thing that could have to do with who
most what literature philosophy we
expose children to would you have any
suggestions for thoughtful children's
books I can't give them Plato but
something better than Harry Potter why
can't you give them Plato it you know
you got to do a little work to support
that but why not give them some short
selections of Plato you can you can give
kids adult books and they can they can
make sense of it
and there's there's you know like a
whole literature out there called
philosophy for children but I don't know
if any of it's any good you know people
like to do things like talk about
Sophie's world I don't I don't read that
sort of stuff and my my kids don't read
that sort of stuff so I don't know then
again there's lots of great fantasy and
sci-fi literature that's raising
philosophical themes you know so maybe
that's that's the stuff to do and you
know the the classic literature that
people could read is really great too I
mean you can even take something like
for example one of the books that I've
been getting ready to do some work on
eventually and rereading as a Song of
Roland right so you this this poem about
Roland and it's about
you know a certain conception of heroism
stemming from the car the carriage in
Ian's age and all that and you know how
anger gets us into a lot of trouble
because they're always constantly
getting angry with each other right you
can even read that and they're gonna be
like I don't understand a lot of these
words I will explain the words to them
and then talk about the big themes was
rolling an idiot for stopping and not
blowing his horn as his friend Oliver
was saying blow that horn
so that Charlemagne can come back and
save our asses or you know was he doing
the right thing and doing that you can
explore these classic motivational
things let's see here let's scroll down
a little bit more alright so it looks
like we don't have a lot of - most
things I'm going to head back up to the
top and start taking some of the other
questions Mike wood how do I read
Dostoevsky and Kafka like what should I
be focusing on focus on reading some
great stories to begin with and don't
worry about what you should be getting
out of it the very first time that you
read it appreciate great literature as
great literature and then whatever you
know ideas that you've equipped yourself
with when they're invoking them you're
going to see them rise to the surface
Kafka and Dostoevsky are well worth
reading just for their own sake then you
can start looking at you know what some
of the key ideas are and how the
characters or the actions or structures
within it exemplify so you might read
the trial and and come across this
notion that's always you know like
captivated me since I read it as an
undergrad of the law court being spread
out through all these addicts throughout
the entire city so existing like
everywhere without us realizing it and
that was that image and the notion of
power that it conveyed was something
that that was incredibly provocative for
me and Kafka just kind of passes over
right you know the characters talk about
it the the main character expresses some
surprise and then they move on
you know the things like that that come
up or you know the characters will
present something think about Ivan
Karamazov and before he gets to the
grand inquisitor chapter what does he do
he presents an argument for it for an
argument from evil against God but he
doesn't simply say therefore God doesn't
exist he wants he's sort of struggling
job like with with God as well so it's
stuff like that that I think you'd pay
attention to let's see Patrick Walters
I'm halfway through being in time if I
made a concise summary when you critique
it I'm so busy with events video
production teaching stuff like that that
I have to give that a pass if you want
if you want me to do things like that
you got to hire me and you got to become
a client and that's the sort of thing I
would do through either tutorials or
through academic coaching because if I
said yes to you I got to say yes to
everybody right out of the blue I get
approached by preferably you know every
other day I've got somebody who wants me
to check something out who wants me to
do something for them in that way and so
I'm tapped out with pro bono work let's
see here money dome on say what's my
opinion on Plato and democracy it
depends on what you mean I mean Plato
was pretty hostile to the democracy of
his time does that mean that he thinks
that democracy will never ever ever ever
work in whatever configuration we have
it doesn't mean that but Plato you know
cautions us about certain tendencies
towards mob like behavior that we see
going on quite a bit a good portion of
it on the left here in America the right
is what's doing it right now we're you
know I mean we were just talking about
this this morning when Obama was in
power you could be a Democrat and
fundamentally disagree with him and
register your disagreement every single
day and that was cool you know you could
be an independent like me and also
register your disagreements as I did
over and over again with with aspects of
his regime
if you're if you're a Republican right
now and you're criticizing Trump from
within the Republican Party you're done
you know they're in lockstep and and the
gyrations that they've had to go through
to especially people who actually has
some principles to begin with to keep
supporting this guy and and what his
administration is doing just disgusting
that's the employer would be looking at
those people and be like holy crap you
know that would be an example of a
demagogue not that there's not
demagogues on the left but Trump is like
the demagogue in chief today so Plato
would be very critical of that hun hang
is that quang how do you respond to
prominent scientists like Lawrence
Krauss and Hawking saying philosophy is
dead I ignore them because they're
stupid there are very smart stupid
people you know I mean to begin with
they don't know that there's like an
entire back history going back about a
hundred 150 years saying philosophy is
dead so they're ignorant to begin with
and poorly informed and then when you
look at like so you read you know
Hawking's he is good physicist right oh
no [ __ ] about metaphysics epistemology
you know theory of time you know he he
doesn't bother like you know actually
reading philosophy and I don't think
these people even have any clue about
what philosophy does it's probably cuz
they belong to universities where the
philosophers are particularly worth a
crap you know but why bother even paying
attention to them when people say stupid
stupid things that's a sign that you
don't need to waste your time on them
right you don't need to like engage
every single possible critic life is
short so Laura - awesome Tony can't we
explore the soul through inspecting the
process be as we experience internally
yeah that people do that throughout the
history philosophy what did David Hume
do what a Descartes do what did Plato do
right what a terrace all do it's not
like they're inspecting it just from the
outside there's there's a lot of
self-introspection and and there's an
assumption to that you know if you can
like look at your own structure then
it's going to be somewhat similar to the
rest of everybody else out there - all
right we're getting close to the the end
here but I think there's quite a few
other questions here
mitko toward arena of greetings from
Bulgaria can you explain to us why
ancient priests switch from multiple
phenomena to a single one the god well I
mean this is kind of an interesting
thing one reason is because some of them
actually thought that the polytheistic
system that they were you know
representing was [ __ ]
I read Cicero's on the nature of the
gods and you see it there's this
character in there who you know as a
Roman priest and he thinks that the
Roman religion is just nonsense you know
he's not replacing it with a
monotheistic religion but you know he's
saying we you know we're carrying out
these sacrifices and laughing at our
sleeves at these stupid ignorant pagans
who bring us their animals to to be
sacrificed
there's you know there's there's there's
a lot of reasons why there's a movement
towards it I'll tell you one thing that
it's not caused by there's a prevalent
you know sort of revisionist history out
there is it was all because of the force
constantine imposed it or some some
nonsense like that developments like
that are very complex right and people
abandon religious and perspectives
because those perspectives no longer
really functioned for them and when they
lose the control when they lose their
hold on the very elites who are carried
out or carrying out those functions
that's a really really bad sign so that
that that's part of it you know I would
say let's see here there's another
question about like the answer to which
is pretty pretty basic it's you don't
need to have the response so hamed
Mondavi what's your response to people
who don't take philosophy seriously and
call it [ __ ] in the form of
chicanery it's grown I mean is it your
job to like
convince everybody about the importance
of philosophy I mean the cool thing is
it's kind of a product that sells itself
people who are gonna tear down
philosophy it's usually because of some
problem on their part and it could some
of it could be because they they
encountered somebody who is teaching
philosophy and they were full of crap
they were uninformed or they were just a
jerk or talked down to them you know
that happens right and then there's all
sorts of like you know people who are
religious or sometimes like you know
Paul told us to avoid false philosophy
you know and you know fine you want to
more yourself and some you know
third-rate reading of the Bible that's
fine you know I mean if you actually pay
closer attention there's a thing called
wisdom literature and the Bible that's
that's philosophy or you know they're
there and there's plenty of people who
are sort of like anti cultural elitist
and they think that by attacking Harvard
where they do philosophy but that it has
anything to do with the people who are
doing philosophy at the you know
four-year liberal arts college down the
road or you know holding popular
sessions or stuff like that and here's
that here's the bottom line
those people are cutting themselves off
from something that's really valuable
that's their problem you don't have to
reach them it's not it's not your
responsibility to like make sure that
they understand that philosophy is more
than their you know reductionist view on
it you know you just keep doing what
you're doing and that and that's fine
mister despair I used what I missed is
through most permanent if it's indeed
part of our our psychology yes it's
interesting because there was one person
again I mentioned Fela love Alexandria
and he you know he wants to transform
the human being so that it no longer has
through most or epithelia and you know
Plato kind of gives a hint about that
because going back to the Timaeus so the
the rational part is is cited here right
that's the immortal part of ourselves
through most epithelia at least in the
Timaeus account are not immortal so
even though there's this you know
Trenton is this a reincarnation we don't
get the same thumos I don't know if that
actually fits well with Plato's other
accounts or that Plato's not always
entirely consistent right between
different dialogues pika well from Earth
so happy I caught this on my lunch break
well I'm glad that that makes you happy
all right what else have we got here
Wow can you compare the most this is
coming from mr. despair to
Schopenhauer's will no you cannot
because Schopenhauer's will is
absolutely fundamental underlies
everything is a very different
metaphysical status than does through
most which is part of a human psychology
if you're a plate nest or an
Aristotelian and at just just an emotion
if you're say a stoic so no it's not
it's not you know open ours will is just
so fundamental the human person comes
out of that you could say build the wall
what are your thoughts on Orthodox
Christianity critique of Catholicism too
much central power in the papacy the
Filioque controversy I ignore all of
that crap because again my life is too
short I don't care you know a lot of
these are such tendentious [ __ ]
critiques anyway similar to like when
Eastern Orthodox people say all sorts of
bad stuff about Anselm
even though they haven't actually read
and saumur they did just with a sort of
you know blinders on about how he's got
this particular theory of the atonement
people who are looking for a fight are
not worth bothering with you know life
is too short again let's see what else
we got here oh here's a good question
Pico Welch Mertz again is are there any
serious discussion to be had about the
theory fiction philosophers like Nick
Landry brassier Graham Graham Hartman's
object-oriented the ontology yeah I'm
just not the guy to do it people have
been asking me about Nick land for a
long
I've been telling people if you want me
to read Nick land send me an actual
physical copy of Fang new mana and I'll
read it but I'm so busy that unless
somebody does that I'm not showing up
money to have it shipped here because I
got I got enough stuff I can work out in
the rest of my life and probably not
make a dent in and yeah there's serious
discussion to be had but not everybody
has to do that I've met Graham Harman
and actually interacted with them not
super impressed with with him but you
know then again he's written quite a few
books and I haven't solved but I don't
find I don't find what he's doing to be
particularly interesting or illuminating
but maybe I maybe I'm missing out on
stuff like let's see what else have we
got here X bluebells can we harness
humanity that someone creates rights
that supersede governments it seems like
governments can just kill without
justification any philosophical concepts
can help you notice yeah they're called
human rights you know or we could say
well what are they based on well maybe
Kant's categorical imperative or you
know some sort of utilitarian
justification just the mere fact that
human rights are not always respected
doesn't mean that it's not an idea out
there there and sometimes they play
incredibly important roles you know you
think about Gorbachev and the deliberate
decision to you know I have perestroika
move away from the Soviet system he did
that because he was influenced by cons
you know and that was in one of the you
know one of one of the political
entities the Soviet Union that had
inflicted horrible misery for us for you
know decades on people in all sorts of
arbitrary ways so you know we don't
always win but philosophical ideas can
play a role all right mark
so someone close to me committed suicide
some years ago they took a victim role
and I would if I lost and I would if I
lost my temper would respond I am
healthy
the most impetuous to live to overcome
to grow I mean when people are when
people are depressed sometimes it's
internalized anger right it's anger
that's had to turn inward on the person
and so if we if we're thinking about it
in terms of thumos the thumos could be
in all sorts of bad configurations
sometimes people kill or harm themselves
because they're they're angry and
they're like screw you I'm gonna show
you you know what you've done to me
right and then I don't know if that's
exactly the sort of thing that you're
you're talking about but so that you
know that can that that's a good
possible configuration for what we're
calling thin walls here all right Samuel
is saying a bunch of nonsense in here
but you know if he wants to stick around
he can all right Nick land I've already
mentioned that let's see here Oh mister
despair favorite book of the Bible see
rock you know I like the wisdom
literature and I particularly like the
wisdom of Ben Ciroc it's not going to be
there in Protestant canons of Scripture
because they narrowed it during the
Reformation but everybody else's Bible
has it in there all the early churches
the Apostolic Church is do so well worth
reading and it's cool because I can read
it in Greek I don't have to feel like
any other stuff I've been reading the
Septuagint I don't read Hebrew so I'm
always like yeah you know this is great
I can read something that's closer and
is canonical and in some sense because
the Alexandria Jews were using it just
fine but I wish I could read the Hebrew
with Ciroc
I mean he knew both of course and Ray
Moss and wire philosophers will being
the wisest so useless they essentially
don't decide anything today why don't
you guys finally take a stance and act
with vigor what a ridiculous question as
people heart the people running major
corporations aren't people who studied
philosophy then get into some research
out there there's all sorts of ways
philosophers are influencing
organizations you know it's it's really
kind of kind of funny in such a big
picture are you all you philosophers man
I work with CEOs and executives and
medical professionals and I do you know
consulting and counseling with them and
is it really like our job to somehow
organize into one big clique who would
offer services you know all right let's
see what else do you get before I gotta
get going
mark says thanks I got to go teach now
marks a long-standing supporter and
subscriber and Friends so good good go
teach and I hope that that things go
well with your students Richard does the
most have anything to do with good and
evil or is it a completely different
quality it's not a quality and like
anything else that can be evaluated in
terms of good and evil right so you're
through most leads you to slit
somebody's throat because you're so
filled with rage and you grab a victim
at random pretty evil right
you're through most leads you to defend
somebody who's being bullied pretty good
right so it can fit in with either of
them let's see here
a lot of thoughts some people are asking
about Peterson or other people that I've
already talked about many many times
ah there's a good thing to head out on
what's up with the half hour Hagel
somewhat sorry of someone else someone
already asked so I haven't been getting
new videos done I'm stuck in the last
part of the morality section so I'm 3/4
of the way through the phenomenology
every month and attempting to get videos
done reading Hegel and talking about
Hegel in front of the chalkboard is
tough and you know it's been one thing
after another after another this has
been a year
a lot of academic teaching for me I
taught in in the fall I taught five
courses in the spring I taught five
courses which is more than full-time for
most people
then I took I'm in the process of
teaching three classes this summer and
I've got another six classes lined up in
the fall so and that's what's turning
down requests for teaching from local
institutions so I've been very busy
doing that you notice I've also been
churning out lots of other video content
and then sometimes when I want to get
half or hagel done my kids are here then
I can't really get much of anything done
or my other relatives are here you know
it's good to keep in mind that I not
only have you know my adoptive family
I've also got my birth family as well so
I yeah so the kind of Wade rights you
deserve a vacation the last vacation
that I had would have been 2013 I have
not had anything like a vacation since
then it's always been working even when
I'm traveling it's you know like doing
presentations or at a conference or
things like that I am hoping to get some
Haegele content shot this month because
I really do want to get back get some
momentum going again I have been holding
my my Hegel Q&A sessions every month you
know but I've just been so so so busy
doing all sorts of other things as well
so all right so I'm going to close on
that because I actually have to head off
now to one of the other local
institutions where I have to figure out
how to set up one of my classes that's
supposed to run in the fall for a prison
students in in the Wisconsin area and
part of the second-chance Pell program
and there's a lot of different hoops and
obstacles to jump through so good
questions and hope that all of you have
a good rest of the day whatever it
happens V morning evening afternoon
middle of the night if you're in some
places and I'll be holding another one
of these on Facebook live later on this
month you see that on my face
or page when it actually comes up I'll
put a little you know announcement about
it in Facebook with an event and yeah
that's about it so I'll talk about
through most more there and I'll see all
of you later on